hello everybody uh really excited to be
giving this talk really excited to be
back in person I came to this uh
conference like pre-covered and it was a
blast I had a really good time just
really like a little like intimidated
and honored to be um
all your people that are working
meeting all the core maintainers
exciting so
it's just a great environment
um so uh yeah so this is the the setup a
little bit I have the links also over
here
um if you miss it you know maybe you
want to take a picture or something like
that uh let me know we can always come
back to it but again data you might want
to download first everything else can go
pretty quickly so I'll wait for phones
to be down at least no I'll kill time
with this slide up so my name is Ben
matorski um I work at the Northeastern
University at The Institute for
experiential AI I've worked in a bunch
of different settings in Private
Industry and Academia and government
um basically every single setting that
I've been in I've done NLP because
there's a wide availability of text Data
text Data seems to be one of the largest
sources that is always there there's
some text component of any sort of data
set that you're working with any sort of
data set that I've worked with so NLP is
a really useful set of tools and all the
open source Community makes it so you
can leverage kind of the state of the
art approaches pretty pretty easily so
the institute for experiential eye just
a little bit of detail about that that
sort of focus there's a research and a
kind of Consulting component I work more
on the Consulting side where I work with
internal and external clients sometimes
on research projects but most of the
time on applications where we actually
build a solution that's going to be
useful for the client but the idea is
experiential AI is sort of human in the
loop understanding subject matter and
getting exemptive matter experts
involved and sort of feeding that
knowledge back and forth between the
application and the uh you know the
subject matter so that's kind of the
idea of it so I'm going to move on from
the slide hopefully I'll have taken that
down uh this is the slide with my face
on it so some motivation here
um I love this this uh this visual this
is from Domo they updated basically
every year
um there's just a massive amount of data
that's being generated every minute
uh there's
there's 5.7 million Google searches uh
slack people are saying sending 140k
messages every minute every day uh which
is a huge amount of data right
um and this is kind of a projection of
like what that data volume kind of looks
like
um and it's just been kind of
exponentially growing uh particularly in
the area of unstructured data and
structured data includes things like
images and video but also and that's
here
so what is natural language does anybody
want to take a stab at this
I have to worry about maybe somebody
wants to try it out they can raise hands
or shout it out
how we speak
yeah
the other
attempts at that
I think it actually is
I I really appreciate that because you
cheat up exactly what I was the point
that I was trying to try to make so
natural language is sort of
self-explanatory it's a language that
developed naturally and you can think of
it in exactly in opposition to
um maybe not in opposition but in
comparison uh to computer language was a
lot more structured it has a flow you
can expect that if you run the same
program then it should have the same
results hopefully
certain program
um but language is a little bit less a
little bit fuzzier there's a lot of
long-term dependencies it changes over
time right the nature of language
doesn't always obey the rules and
sometimes the
subversions of the rules have meaning in
itself think of negation and things like
that when you say this was good versus
this is not good very similar words
completely different meanings
um so it's it's uh it's a more it's a
differently it has a different set of
things that are need to be taken into
account when you're thinking about them
um I really like this uh visual of tree
progression of natural language
processing we moved from a very kind of
tailored small data kind of approach
where there's a lot of emphasis on
understanding language and Linguistics
expertise was kind of built in and now
we've moved into this Paradigm of deep
learning where it's less transparent but
the the need for machine learning
expertise is higher and the need for
linguistic expertise Linguistics has
sort of like been pushed a little bit to
the side you can just expect the model
to understand these patterns
and not to say one is better than the
other we've made some decisions that
have gotten us to this kind of world
those decisions are worth considering
and taking into account actually this
talk is really interesting but you know
gold Goldberg he says we should push
towards using both expertise both
Linguistics and machine learning
expertise which I think is an
interesting kind of initiative
so now that we're in this like really
big data deep learning kind of world we
can do really kind of cool things and
this is uh hugging faces like just kind
of Showcase of Transformer models and
just you can have them sort of you know
write your own presentations for you
right or I say I'm a data scientist and
I everything in bold is written by the
model right the model
just based on that context what to fill
in and it's it's words right it makes
sense it's legible it's not very useful
or informative but it is like language
right it has
um
and then people have probably heard
about this Dali uh or stable diffusion
you know it's like I feel like I've made
this slide and then a month later
they're a stable diffusion and then it's
like opens it so everything has changed
in like even in the past like few months
but
um basically just from combinations of
representations of images and text uh
it's able to given a prompt to create
pretty
novel interesting Recreation of what you
sort of specify in the text right an
illustration of a baby Daikon radish is
a two to walking a dog very specific
right but it's all there right all the
components are there
um
so I think that's that's pretty amazing
but this is going to be always going to
be a comma butt in like most of the
things I'm going to talk about today
um the data is weak whatever you put
into your model has the same uh is going
to transplant his biases uh into your
results right so this is from Dolly
particularly example
um if you put in uh like a flight
attendant or a lawyer you can see that
there's some very specific stereotypes
that have it has intro the model has
internalized and how that shakes out may
not be as obvious as this but it's there
foreign
so more interactive here right
um so structured data I'm going to give
kind of
hand wave the explanation of what
structured data is conforms to a data
model has a consistent order it's
quantifiable so then we have some
examples of what the structured what
structured data might be
a table oh a table Yeah like a format
the data model yeah yeah so that's
that's definitely one yeah but like what
kind of what might be in the table I
guess is sort of what I was more what
kind of information might be structured
yeah
it's like a big scale survey data yeah
right like a likert scale or something
like that from one to five right
um and so what's the difference between
let's take that example likert Square
scale like what is the difference
between something like a likert scale
and
text data
it's sort of a finite amount of values
that you can have right and you know the
order of them right they have an
intrinsic kind of value in them text is
not so simple like that right so if you
think about like height weight you know
that
um you know 12 inches in a foot right
there's some conversion metrics there's
there's already value attached to it and
text is not so clear right like what do
you is duh you know three times like the
like the letter A like it's not it's not
it's not clear that that's how it works
um also one of the things I'm gonna come
back to a few different times is
long-term dependencies so it's uh the
example is like you know like Ben
watched the movie he didn't like it he
goes all the way back to the started
sense
right and like being able to establish
those long-term dependencies is a really
tricky problem
in
I'm gonna posit that this is sort of the
purpose of NLP
it's kind of a working definition so if
you disagree I definitely would love to
hear your thoughts on it
um but in like the perfect Universe you
can have a perfect response to every
input text like a human might have right
like
call center somebody's answering it
maybe it'll not be perfect but it's like
approximating like a
response to the input
um but you don't have an infinite call
center right you have to create some
kind of heuristics
um so you need to be able to create some
kind of informative representation to
the text input use that representation
for some purpose right it's a
classification is it grouping is it
anything like that is it similarity
things like that we're going to actually
be using one particular like utilization
we're not going to vary the utilization
in that we're going to be using a
sentiment analysis
um task but the thing that we're going
to vary a lot is this informative
representation
foreign
ly off the wall
anybody want to complain about it right
now
so
there'd be like a more
like reach goal that's more like
understanding language in some sense as
opposed to just giving an accurate
response back yeah I think that's a
really that's a good point right I guess
some that's something that's missing
here is the understanding it's just
reaction that sort of being focused on
yeah that's a really good point and I
think that's yeah I think a lot of
people are challenged or tackling that
challenge
and we'll actually talk about a little
bit
um that just
internalizing patterns the model just
internalize the pattern that doesn't
necessarily need to understand
cool so uh I'm gonna be giving an
overview of basically all of this so I
know it seems a little intimidating but
what what's going to happen is we're
going to sort of give a survey over
these I'm not going to dive super deep
into any particular topic
um there'll also be code don't worry
code is coming
um uh but we won't also be diving too
deeply into the code itself the idea is
to give a survey of these approaches uh
how they sort of feed into each other
kind of the pros and cons of each and
what one tries to solve versus another
try to get a conceptual understanding
and a light touch on the code as well uh
I tried to cram a lot into this and I
definitely left a lot of them a lot on
The Cutting Room floor but uh I think
these are useful techniques and things
that I can sort of drag a story through
the entirety of it
um I also have this like timed for like
an hour ish I can fill up more time but
like definitely Break in with questions
if I'm going too fast or going too slow
or anything like that uh throughout I
would have that'll be great
yes sorry thank you yes and I'll try to
repeat the questions because otherwise
great
so the data set that we're going to be
using uh is a review data set from IMDb
it's 50 000 uh reviews labeled for
sentiment positive versus negative
um
uh why this data set
uh it's for those reasons it's easy to
access it's simple it's pretty balanced
the passages are relatively clean
um but the problem with that is that
basically any problem that I've ever
encountered is none of those things
um so uh take that with a great thought
I also have particular feelings about
um sentiment analysis just as a
the initial generally but it's a nice
clean
objective so we're gonna use it
and also I like I had extracted the
titles but like they're tight it's like
kind of a random selection of titles run
I do DB it's not like all like Star Wars
and stuff like that so it's
unfortunately it's gonna be hard to like
look at the words and be like oh I
understand that review
these are the tools that we'll be using
uh scikit-learn Focus thank you very
much
um Spacey which is extremely powerful
I've done another talk on Spacey for NLP
uh it's an awesome Library if you're
really interested in digging into LP I
highly recommend it we're not going to
use it for that much but it is very
useful
um Transformers which is uh also plugs
into Spacey actually
um which gives us access to kind of The
Cutting Edge type models and it has a
really nice interface and Pie torch for
some deep learning applications
okay so let's get started start with the
basics right you learn about the body
you start with like cells you learn
about text analysis you start with
tokens
um so a token basically is defined as a
useful so
and you can make a bunch of decisions
about what is a useful semantic unit
um a lot of those decisions in more in
the more like cutting edge things Bert
makes a bunch of decisions about that
tokenization you don't even see it but
it's something that you should know
happens underneath because it might
change based on your different domain or
if you have a different language
um yeah actually an example of that is I
worked in one research project that was
using Chinese and something that I
didn't know about Chinese before I
started working with it is there's not a
clear definition of like white space
right or a clear definition of like
um it's not always just like one
character it's not always individual
characters sometimes with multiple
characters and sometimes characters
together mean something different from
their characters individually
um and so a lot of the token isolation
strategies use kind of like a
probabilistic approach where they're
just like well these usually appear
together so we're going to split them
like that
um I don't know if people have other
examples like that right I am really
always interested in hearing about other
languages and how their tokenization
like considerations are totally
different from English
anyone have any examples
we're all English focused
yeah like like emojis would be one yeah
somebody asked a question about emojis
uh last time we gave a talk and I was
like I don't really know like I I don't
know how you would process those okay
um yeah so that's sort of like
tokenization is one strategy you might
want to think about uh a lot of times
we're just gonna be splitting on white
space because it's simple
um and then if you have multiple tokens
in a row you call that something like if
you have two tokens really called bigram
um you have seven tokens in a row you
call it seven seven grams so on so forth
um so you can see with this example I'm
learning natural language processing uh
if you just look at the unigrams you
have every single sort of white space
split token um and then by grams and so
on and so forth
um
yeah
book anxiety and strategy is important
it's it's worth considering how your
tokens are being split and whether those
are the use spaces
so
you know half the presentation title is
bagging so this is essentially what uh
bagging is I have a lot of examples
around football teams I have no idea why
I don't really care about football and I
imagine that
probably this is the wrong audience to
have football uh references but whatever
it's fun
um so uh say you have these two
different we're going to call them
documents right uh I am a patron I'm a
Giants fan you are essentially doing the
white slate split and then you're
throwing all the individual tokens into
a bag and I have them specifically out
of order because the point is these do
not have Order anymore once you start
throwing them in the back
um and then say if you have only two
documents you can kind of arrange them
in this idea of a document term Matrix
and right now you have essentially a
representation your our first kind of
representation of a document which is
just uh accounts across the entire
vocabulary and because we you know added
another document because we have this we
have this document in this document and
these documents one there's only one
difference of words we already sort of
are expanding our vocabulary and we'll
get back to that how the dimensions sort
of expanded as you had more documents to
your inventory
but that's the bagging kind of mentality
um and so this document term Matrix or
this word count already we can start
doing NLP on this we already can start
deriving some really useful information
from here so this is from uh speech and
language processing book is amazing and
also free online so highly recommend it
um they use a lot of examples from uh
Shakespeare and just like word counts
and things like that from Shakespeare
um and you have Shakespeare's comedies
and Shakespeare's histories and can
anybody tell me
just from this word count what they can
maybe I'll conclude or infer about the
differences between how many of
Industries
okay
different word choice different word
choice
yeah yeah right exactly exactly so
certain words like battle like if a a
play contains a number of references to
battle you can probably be more
confident if you're just comparing the
comedies in history is that it's a
history
um which is pretty cool and like that's
something that I'm not going to go into
but there's a bunch of sort of
statistical measures that you can use
like a log likelihood
um that can tell you you know what our
very like characteristic words
of a particular category
and for that you don't need Bert you
don't need fancy you know deep learning
you
does that make sense
or disagree
to The Notebook all right now I promise
there'd be code and so I'm gonna make
good on that promise
um so does everybody is everybody able
to pull this up um I don't know if folks
are familiar with collab has anybody
been struggling at all is it kind of
working
what you'll want to do uh also and I
should have mentioned this before
because it takes a minute is you're
going to want to upload uh the reviews
um pickle
Style
uh to your summit workspace
and you want to do this for both of the
different parts of it
not hearing anybody complain something
they just keep going
um so we're gonna import a bunch of
stuff
um we're gonna ignore
uh caution here
caution to win
um this is a bunch of code for just how
I took the raw data set and turned it
into the pickle file just for reference
um we're going to make the label
essentially dude that's exactly what I
mean
um
so we're just going to use this instead
so if you get a problem like that that
means Google uh collab did a bad job of
uploading the file so you're probably
yeah
okay maybe that'll maybe that's the
problem oh maybe that's a problem I
don't know last time I tried to run it I
just have to do this again
um but whatever we'll try
um either way I have it I have it up
here so we can
hold back
um so we're just going to make the label
uh
Boolean if it's true with positive it's
false is negative it's just easier to
use for that purpose
um and now we're just going to look at
just what our data set kind of looks
like because that's an important thing
to do usually
um so we have a negative review and we
have a positive review I don't know
which movie this is
um
but I don't know they didn't like it
it's kind of surprising uh but uh
something we can do with base python is
we can take our negative review and we
can just apply a counter to its split
just by Nature on white space and we get
uh essentially a word count for that
particular review and that's just base
python
pretty easy to do but we're going to be
using scikit-learn just because it
doesn't really it makes this really easy
and that's what I've always been using
and second learn has a count vectorizer
which essentially does a similar thing
it does some uh has a bunch of defaults
about how it's splitting tokens so you
would want to look into that if you are
interested in doing a different
tokenization strategy but we're just
using all the defaults we're fitting it
to this individual review and it's going
to give us a sparse Matrix of help
um you can you know very easily just get
this to an array get the future names
from the vectorizer and
to kind of manipulate it and essentially
you can get the same thing back out
you can get a dictionary of words with
their counts
can anyone tell me
what's different between this counter
object and this
and this dictionary that we produced
or any differences they observe
there's one particular difference in
vehicle that's it all lowercase
it's all lowercase yeah that's exactly
it so one of the defaults and this is
just like a catch one of the defaults is
it lowercase is all your text which is
you know useful in some cases some cases
that might not be that useful so for
example the and I think there's a
lowercase somewhere
anyway that is uh the capital is
considered a different token then there
we go so the lowercase yeah
yeah
question and this might be getting a
little bit ahead but one thing I think
you just
was there and it's sort of relevant to
my work also you have uh names of people
like Alan Rickman Emma Thompson for
example and in these cases is there a
way to identify names and to put the
five grams of documents
that is a really great question so the
question was is there a way to identify
um uh particular sets of tokens that
should hang together in some way like
names or something like that like Alan
Rickman
um and that is a whole sort of area
called named entities where we would
call that a named entity because it's an
entity that actually has like a real
world
um it's actually naming something like
the the whole uh the whole set of tokens
together is actually
like New York City right is an example I
always point to right it's three
different like white space split tokens
but they don't like the individual units
need something different from them all
together
um not going to necessarily talk about
that I do have another talk that I talk
about near identity recognition so
definitely uh recommend looking into
that but yeah there are ways of
approaching that there's you know out of
the box models that do that kind of
recognition problem but yes it is
important to treat them as it's somewhat
different from you know the individual
like new
on its own should be treated differently
from New York City
that makes sense
um okay so the first thing I always like
to do in any like uh uh data science
application that I do is like doing a
determatistic approach because it's very
easy uh it'll be very quick and
sometimes maybe like predicting the mean
is what you want to do right like that
maybe that's right and it's good to set
a baseline for your performance right
how how basically low can you go that
was the dumbest approach right
um so this deterministic approach is
essentially just saying we have an
inventory of positive words we have an
inventory of negative words and we're
just going to subtract the score from
each other and treat that as kind of a
threshold whether this is a positive or
negative review
very simple and also this like list of
words is very very tiny there are
smarter ways to do sentiment analysis
where there's actually like a larger
inventory of words that are scored a
little bit more informatively and then
one credit like use beta the Vader
package
back in the day
um it's it was it was very quick one of
the nice things is it just can score
these words like that right
um not very good but it's it's quick
right
um sorry I don't mean they I think
there's now more advanced sort of
scoring that that does I don't want to
throw that library in the best
um but yeah so that's what we're doing
here
uh we're also doing this train test
split here
um which we'll be using kind of
throughout the entire thing
yeah
so this is also we're going to look at
both accuracy and the classification
report uh particularly looking at the F1
score we can already see that this
doesn't do very well but this set's a
nice like Baseline for us to start
foreign
so now let's go with our count
vectorizer so now we're not going to
just use the defaults we're going to
remove things that are called stop words
so things like and the but words that
are we're assuming to be uninformative
um so I can learn has a set of these
already kind of uh inside of it
but um you know you can always add
additional stop words that you don't
think are going to be that useful we're
also restricting the number of um
restricting our vocabulary only to words
that appear in at least one percent of
the entire Corpus uh because if we don't
you have 80 000 unique tokens
um and even with this reduction we get I
forgot exactly how many
have it somewhere a few thousand tokens
so that's we're setting up our account
factorizer I'm going to be using this
pipeline
um uh functionality which I think is
awesome but I'm also not going to really
be explaining it but essentially all you
need to know is that it can stitch
different components of us I can learn
pipeline together
um very highly recommend
we're going to use logistic regression
and essentially that's what we're going
to be using throughout
fairly simple I just found this was this
ran a little bit easier and didn't
complain as much so I added a higher Max
inter iterations so we're going to run
that we're going to score it and we're
going to get a classification report out
of it and we're going to get oh I need
to update that number
um we're going to get it doing very very
well and spoiler this is basically like
we've topped out a performance with this
approach and there are good they're like
caveats and like good and bad to that
point that I want to make is that even
with a simple method we're actually
doing really
the other caveat is a lot of the other
methods
are not going to be tuning to two and so
they probably go higher if we actually
did more tuning to it
um and that this model applied to
something outside of the IMDb data set
is probably not going to do as well
because it's fit to a particular
vocabulary and that vocabulary size
is
um
believe it's something like
I think counts
huh
and say how large this vocabulary is oh
okay it's not that large I thought it
was larger than that
um
Dimensions essentially to this uh
this input
and again the representation here I feel
like it needs to keep coming back to the
representation is where it counts here
so each document is represented as a
vector of word counts so that's the
representation our utilization of that
representation is a logistic regression
the classifying positive does that make
sense
too fast too slow
faster slower
just right
perfect I don't see any feedback at all
so I'm gonna be yeah just right perfect
uh great so
um that is Count uh
word counts rather
um
so we're gonna just keep track of this
and keep coming back to that
representation we have this documentary
Matrix is our word count uh and our F1
score is pretty good
um but something that you might notice
in those word counts is that every
single uh word instance every single
word is counted exactly the same
um but we know if we're going to create
informative representations that there
are probably words that are more
important or tokens that are more
important to our problems than others
right and so there might be a way of
collapsing sort of uninformative tokens
into uh one particular token there might
be stripping uninformative words like
soft Words which we've already sort of
done
um
but you also might want to kind of
create a waiting regimen where you
upweight words that are informative and
down weight towards their uninformation
and one kind of very simple way of
implementing that waiting is term
frequency inverse document frequency it
sounds scary but it's extremely simple
term frequency we already have right if
the word counts that we've already done
document frequency is how often a
particular token appears across all the
documents and then if you just invert
that document frequency value you get uh
very common words being down weighted
and very uncommon words being operated
simple as that right and you can see it
you can you can calculate it essentially
by hand because it's apparently it's
just straightforward
um in this expression I am a fan of
Patriots or Giants whatever you like
um we understand that I am a fan those
tokens are not that informative because
they're the same across both the
documents but the informative thing is
the team
um so just because of the nature of this
very simplistic example we just get
patrons and Giants waited at just like
one these instances occurs once and it
just uh is weighted at one
um and uh fan we get down weighted
0.5
that makes sense
simple
easy
and then the thing that I want to bring
home is I'm not going to really explain
cosine similarity but cosine similarity
is a way of comparing these two vectors
to each other and if you just use the
word count the raw word count these two
word counts are scored as pretty uh
close to each other so higher means more
similar lower means less similar but we
know that Patriots fans and Giants fans
are very different so we want to make
sure that that is represented in our
data and so TF IDF vectors are
less similar
does that make sense
any questions there
hearing none
move on to the notebook back to the
notebook
um so tfidf this is just almost the
exact same example I just gave where the
movie was is shared across all these
different documents and it's just the
you know what is the actual adjudication
at the end that that it matters and if
you do count Vector it treats everything
the same if you do TF IDF vectorizer you
get
um the words that are pretty common down
weighted um so I kind of am being like
iffy with language here by saying this
like separability better separability is
it's not like like true right because
this uh in this count in these count
vectors we have ones and zeros right
like it appears or it doesn't appear so
it's actually same amount of
separability
but you can imagine that if you want to
create this informative representation
you want that representation to contain
more information of what's informative
so
separability may not be the right word
but
you can sort of see it's doing what we
expect it to do and then we can just
plug the TFI so there's a there's a
compactorizer there's a TFI of TF IDF
vectorized that operates sort of in the
same principle you can plug that into
our Pipeline and then we can get results
and the results are like comparable it's
like this almost the same as the count
vectorizer
what is nice is maybe we saw a little
bit of a bump in the recall
um Small Bump in the recall and uh
I guess I don't
yeah I don't need to go into all of this
but this was just a way that I kind of
wanted to do of looking at the different
um actually coefficients in Middle
District regression for these different
um terms in the vocabulary just to show
what is the difference between like how
much the model that's trained on tfid
Works versus the model is trained on
count vectors and just to show that like
yeah I mean this is I'm not going to go
through all the code but um
the
model is essentially learning more from
the word Chad or tfidf than it is from
uh
the count Vector
um just by how the magnitude of the the
coefficients
yeah the idea that like
bad is a important word that we expect
of the model will use to identify
whether it's positive or negative review
but right because language is complex
maybe the use of the word bad is
it could be badass right or something
like that I don't know if they're gonna
censor that
um
I feel like that's that's sort of what I
wanted to look at I have some other code
here for like if you want to compare
um does that all make sense
yeah
just wondering what the
if you ever like white differently like
squid inverse
yeah so the question is have you ever
done any different like other
transformations to that that waiting
um I haven't that's an interesting
it's an interesting idea
um yeah I mean it's you know tfidf it's
just a way of waiting of like it comes
from a field of information extraction
or information retrieval rather
um where the idea is you're trying to
get the most informative information out
of
um
uh out of the text
so yeah it's
together
any other thoughts questions
complaints yeah so so based on the table
above we can get a sense of which words
are more predictive of positive versus
negative yeah it's a little bit like I
got myself into because I just I was
just doing this as kind of an
exploration but essentially it's just
kind of looking at the magnitude of the
coefficients just including that as a
proxy is of how much uh how much the
model is relying on that for
um uh its prediction
um and this is kind of a ranking and so
uh the tfidf ranks bad and more
yeah sorry that's why I just like kind
of glossed over it and
[Music]
but this is like a very simple like
what I recommend you do
a physical sense yeah go ahead
um you didn't do any spell checking or
normalizing normalization no yeah no
spell checking no normalizing to the
if you want to mess around with the data
you'll see that there's like
it's like um like kind of garbage tokens
in there
um it's pretty clean but if you actually
I spent a lot of my career doing web
scraping and I have like PTSD from that
because you'll have that problem like
and it's almost like intractable to like
get rid of all of the garbage but yeah
does it change anything if you
like monetize it or try to do
[Music]
it like yeah so the question is does it
change anything if you do anything so
it's a similar sort of question where
like where like more normalization
individual tokens
um I haven't I haven't tried it but yeah
usually you will get that and like
that's a it's like a nice pre-processing
step so limitization is one of the
is essentially what I was referring to
like here where I am and I will uh the
sort of root form of Will and M or is B
so you can turn everything to B and then
you get accounts from B rather than
counts for am will and B like
um
and so yeah it would probably would help
model some some degree but
there's a bunch of pre-processing again
a bunch of stuff that I'm not going into
this bunch of pre-processing stuff in
them
uh I don't know if I have a good
reference of like a set of
the Spacey is really useful for that
because basically has a lot of like
attributes to individual tokens that you
can use for your pre-processing
um so I don't know if that's a useful
answer to your question
I'm more just curious about your you
know what's your experience been and
what the outcome
if that pre-processing
it's worth it I mean I think the
pre-processing is almost free so it may
make sense to do it and try it anyway
um
yeah I mean the stop words
though there's always like a like you
know it's a kind of thing
if you're dealing where dealing with
like text and sequence right if you
actually do have
um can maintain the order I've seen
applications where they uh are like
running like a current model spoiler
running a recurrent model and they
remove
and it's like why would you ever do that
right because it's not words carry
information and particularly the context
in which they appear carrying
information and bagging you can sort of
understand it because you want to like
condense
vocabulary but
it's not always the right thing to do
that was a long-winded answer to your
question but yes it's worth trying
because it's not it's not it's not hard
to
especially with the tools thank you open
source especially with the tools that
are out there it's it's crazy
cool so here's our progress so far
um
you know we haven't gone too far
um but uh this is something I've sort of
made reference to before that our
vocabulary expands as we add more
documents to it right if we just took
just this subset of uh literature we get
like thousands of unique words right
um and uh I put in Shakespeare's play
because we were using examples from
Shakespeare but Shakespeare play has a
lot of words as well
um a lot of unique words as well so uh
anybody want to explain what the curse
of dimensionality is
mainly asking so I can take a drink of
water the number of teachers girls are
very good industry yeah when it grows
too yeah when it gets to sort of out the
number of features uh out outgrows the
number of observations essentially you
can have your model for example just
memorize the data exactly which might be
useful for that approach but not always
um so does anybody have
like
tools that they use to combat Liquors of
dimensionality I believe the curse of
dimensionality is such like dramatic
curse
um but how do people fight this curse
clustering
yeah clustering is one approach does
anybody have other approaches
words
yeah I mean spoiler but yes yeah
so that's what we're we've been using
that like Min DF uh keyword uh is is
um I guess maybe it's a simpler question
that I'm asking is sort of
dimensionality reduction is one approach
right
um and that's essentially what we're
going to get into here when we talk
about topic models
um and the idea of a topic model is that
essentially every document is composed
of a set of different topics and those
topics themselves are composed of a set
of different words
um and how this is operationalized is
essentially just like a dimensionality
all right a single Vector decomposition
one of the ones that we're going to be
using is Matrix factorization
is really really well uh
David Blair has a really interesting I
think this is actually the article the
2012 article where he talks about you
know
it's our article
um about Leighton dear play
allocation which is another approach
we're going to be doing non major
factorization comes faster and sometimes
works better
um but the idea is you want to reduce
the number of Dimensions without losing
a lot of information and those
Dimensions those latent Dimensions that
you extract we're calling topics and
just in this
world
um this is just a visual that I like it
sets up something later so uh say you
have your data in two Dimensions you can
extract Dimensions that better explain
the variability in the data this is not
that impressive when you go from two
Dimensions the two Dimensions but if you
have for example 1500 Dimensions like
1500 different tokens uh it's a lot more
impressive to go down to two
um this might be more uh exciting to
folks like this is an example that we
actually like actually used in real life
um yes you can use NLP in real life
um I worked on a like a B2B company
where we had these small businesses that
didn't fall neatly into any particular
category
um because those categories tend to be
fit to larger companies so this is an
example near where I live where it's a
yoga studio that also has a health food
store and also has a restaurant in it so
it doesn't really fall into any one of
these categories and we were thinking
that well that's probably true for a lot
of these businesses your business is
kind of straddle a few different
categories so could we create uh more
kind of uh nuanced representation of
what is the the content of that business
what is that business doing uh and one
approach to that is doing these topic
models and uh I really like the visual
in the middle here of
it's called a termite plot I believe
where essentially we're visualizing each
three of the topics that were extracted
from the topic model and the relevance
of a particular word to that topic so
all the words have some loading on each
of the topics but certain words load
more heavily on particular topics
um and just by looking at this somebody
looking at this what could you maybe
tell me about one of these topics
foreign
I should mention that these models don't
give you out of the box like what the
topic is about it's sort of a top-down
decision and so that it you know injects
its own amount of noise and you might
you know see patterns that may not
actually be there
um but what's nice about this is you get
like a nice interpretable kind of
understanding of like what uh a lot of
ways these are pretty clear topics you
know I'm cherry picking a little bit
what are the topics and what are the
words that I'm showing
um but this is easy to sort of share
with somebody that has no familiar
underlining mechanisms
um and then you can get every single
business kind of uh represented right uh
each business considered considered as a
document represented across these
different uh topics
so the representation we're doing in
this case is going to be these these
topic vectors
any questions there
yeah go ahead
yes
the number of topics yeah
um so the question is how do you tune
the number of topics and the answer is
I'm not sure
the answer is you tune in until that so
that's the cash about this the
unsupervised kind of approach where you
are going to
I got a question similar to this right
like uh if the topics are useful for
your model
um then they are useful right like for
whatever your Downstream application is
um if it's uh yielding good results then
that is the number of topics you should
use right um and you can always like
tune these and play around with it uh
with like this like say you set up this
Pipeline and you can see the performance
if you try different numbers of topics
right so you can tune that a little bit
but again it's like a you know it's like
a fuzzy kind of like art thing less than
a particular science
um
yeah but right sorry I should also say
that in these topic models you're you're
usually picking the number of topics you
expect to come out
that's kind of a hard decision to make I
just arbitrarily choose 10. it's because
it's a nice number and that's what I'm
going to do here so we're back here I
have this useful utility for just
displaying the important uh words for a
particular concept uh sorry topic and so
I'm choosing just 10 components I'm
setting up the non-negative Matrix
factorization with some just things that
make it work a little better
um
uh nmf likes TF IDF
um vectors can be pulled into it it
likes to be fit on tfidf vectors rather
than count vectors so
I used to know why and now I don't uh
yes for some reason it just it seems to
work better with that uh and then if we
can if we're gonna apply this uh display
components to it you'll actually see
something useful come out of it I
probably should have just not run it
right now but um
what you'll see is it'll give you the
top set of words that are most relevant
to that topic and
if it ever finishes
um you can see this does anybody see
anything interesting about these topics
foreign
comedy related
yeah it seems to become right
afterwards yeah
yeah one and three should be the same
yeah yeah I have a hard time
understanding those ones
um
but what if it's about the movie Saw
it could be but then that probably would
be so the other one that I thought was
particularly interesting is thing is one
is topic seven that is horror and Gore
um
yeah budget effects maybe less so it's
you know it's not it's not a perfect
decomposition here but if we just say if
we look at the
um so remember that out of this we get a
representation across all the topics for
each individual document
YouTube um and say we sort these reviews
by they're particularly loading like how
much that particular topic is relevant
to that
um that review if we sort them and just
look at the top ones for this topic
seven we get are reviews reviews for
horror movies
now this is the top two right if we went
further down we might not see as clean
uh an example but
this is a fairly easy uh model to fit uh
and you'll get some useful stuff out of
it
um so we're going to essentially do the
same thing if we did before except this
time we're going to use
um nmf uh
and we're gonna set up that Pipeline and
you know here's the results
but the accuracy is worse but remember
we're going from 1500
Dimensions to 10. so for sure we're
losing some amount of information
um and we haven't really done much in
the way of tuning uh and actually if you
add a little bit like a smaller set of
like text features this is
um if we just like subset the actual TF
IDF to just the words that appear at
least five percent of documents uh you
get you know a bump in performance
you know things need to be tuned a
little bit
a little bit all these other things but
you do get something interpretable out
of it it's useful for understanding what
are relevant words and useful as like a
any questions there
yep
it is so this is very it seems very
similar to the PCA like principles is it
is it just that or is it yes yeah so
like PCA
um uh operationalization PCA is uh
latent semantic indexing which is
another it's not really like a topic
model because they're not uh like
additive the different components
um but you can do uh there's a lot of
examples of using like semantic indexing
reducing the dimensionality
of text
accounts word counts
so yes yeah
not negative factorization doesn't have
to be applied to text
it's nice because it's
the thing that I didn't really I could
talk about or glossed over was
essentially you get these additive
components so each
um each uh topic is the loading is
positive right it's harder to understand
if a topic loading is negative
right because like what is it it's less
r e like it's hard to understand that
all right hearing no other questions I'm
gonna move right along to we have the
spoiler over there
um
so this is just taking up this video
this visual just keyed up this point
right so you have these nice topics
vectors say explain your data really
really well you're very very happy and
then you get more data and you're like
dang
um so now it doesn't explain your uh
your data quite as well
um so what you might do is you know fit
another topic model you might want to do
this iteratively you might put like a
ton of data together and fit the best
and greatest topic model and essentially
what you would be doing in that case
um is uh getting into this area that we
sort of that is sort of referred to as
transfer learning or essentially you
want to learn a set of topics that is
generally applicable across all texts
ever and you know spoiler we're not
going to be using the topic model
Paradigm for this but you could right
you could just take you could try and
fit the best topic model that explains
all text ever uh it's probably gonna be
a very hard task so it's going to be
operationalized a little bit differently
but what is what transfer learning is
essentially just kind of traditional
machine learning you take your task and
you put it through your learning system
take another task put it through your
Learning System but for sure there are
shared elements of the data and shared
elements of the tasks that you might be
able to if you put your data together
and get some representation of knowledge
and then pass that to your next uh your
next Learning System to sort of boost it
to give it some more juice
um
I love this visual the visual is like I
feel like it's so an informative way of
explaining it
um and so what we're going to use is our
source task in this case rather than
like topic modeling is we're going to
use term co-occurrence statistics and
this uh there's a ton you can do with
how often a word occurs with another
word and basically there's some people
that argue that this is all of modern
NLP uh is just you know different
operationalizations of term coccurrence
which is true in a way but this again
comes from uh the speech and language
processing uh looking at instead of a
document term Matrix we're looking at a
term term maintenance that's how often
two terms appear together in uh
Courtney's
um and just looking at this what does
this what can you tell about the
relationship uh between pi and Cherry
versus pi and digital
foreign
what does that sort of bring to mind
like what do you what does that make you
think they're related right that there's
some relationship between the two that
makes it more likely that they occur
together than
um for example Pi with digital or Pi
with you know another term unless you're
working with you know like Raspberry Pi
or something like that that's the
difference
Corpus or something
um but right so and you know you could
say you already have kind of informative
representation of each individual token
here and here we're actually going to be
talking about representations for
individual tokens individual words
um and so you could actually say like
this is a like a vector that describes
this word to some degree but you know
it's a little bit hard you know you get
into that same problem where you have
every single different word you get a
huge dimensional vector and so it
probably makes sense to
fit a model to this co-occurrent
Statistics
um and there's this distributional
hypothesis that kind of governs the kind
of thinking that you know a word you can
say that a word is related because they
uh occur together
um and so there's a couple of different
approaches to this there's more than
this but
um word to back which is used as a
neural model uh based on these
co-occurrence uh information
um and then gloves which uses
Cochran statistics
to create these representations and the
idea is you're going to learn you're
going to have your model learn a
numerical Vector for each word based on
its context and those individual
dimensions are not readily interpretable
um they just uh do a good job of
representing the you know patterns the
the co-occurrence information of that
particular
in context of other words
um and so the canonical example is that
the distance between the the vector for
king and queen is the same as the
distance between the vector before man
and woman and that makes intuitive sense
right that that makes meaning sense in
in our minds but that's not necessarily
what this is fit to so I'm this is the
caveat comma but uh just because it's
it's all fit to co-occurrent statistics
Cochran says something about meaning it
is not meaning is not the same thing as
needed so these vectors I you know I say
this because when I first like learned
when it was you know young and fresh and
I first learned about uh like these word
embeddings I was like oh it understands
the meaning it's the representation of
meaning and it's not it's a
representation of co-occurrence
so those two things are different
but it's still super powerful right
because like just be like by this
representation carries with it some
information that we can do
um that is that is useful for
understanding like the relationship to
other words and uh what it can be uh
yeah where it's used like how it's being
used
Circle
any questions on that I know there's
like one slide on all of we're embedding
so it's a little bit
maybe this is a bit philosophical but
yeah
a system the word capture meaning to
look like yeah what would I consider a
system that would capture meaning
yeah I don't know
it's a good question
yeah
I mean
Cool Chris is a good proxy for me
but it's not necessarily like I guess I
struggled I'm not sure if I have a clear
answer to that
um question I don't know if a system
yeah
I feel like a system like that would
have to build in a lot of linguistics
information like this is just saying
find a pattern represent that pattern
right uh it's not there's no uh uh
boundaries on that
there's no uh if you just fit it to just
the giant data set what is the data set
that's going into
because it'll have a very different
representation if you give it a bunch of
biological text versus a bunch of random
Reddit posts right
um and so like
I don't know if that's really that
useful but a system would have to build
in like more of what we use right when
we're learning language right where we
would understand uh what like a certain
particular context works with what uh
the modifiers on those contexts are and
like sort of bounds the space a little
bit more than just extracts patterns
that was a hard question thank you for
the question but I don't know if that
was a satisfactory answer
um so you also get other cool spatial
characteristics
um from this uh I really like this talk
it was really interesting
um
but
um this is basically taking the word
embedding
um algorithm and training it on job
postings
and does anybody see like
anybody characterize these little boxes
of words what they might be knowing that
we've
all looked at job postings before
I think these were technical job
postings too right
too right yeah
so like what is what would you describe
this red
Ness yes
or confidence yeah skills and
competencies yeah
yeah and then there's like sort of the
requirements the job requirements and
things like that so like yeah so just by
like decomposing into two Dimensions
right you have these these vectors that
uh can be these these word bettings
which can be a number of different
dimensions but a lot of times they're
200 dimensions and
collapse into two dimensions and you can
see a lot of the spatial relations
it's really interesting talk Miriam
uh
and comma butt right this is
considerations when using these
embeddings that they will also build in
the bias of the data that you feed them
I think this visual is really cool
because it talks about how gendered I'm
gonna try to explain this in a easy way
how gendered the
the actual representations of these of
words are and there's uh kind of a shift
that happens around the 1960s in the the
genderedness of language that sort of
coincides with a lot of the women's uh
rights movements where you which you can
imagine sort of change the reference
change how language was being used
particularly around gender
and you can see like a very strong
correlation in up until the 60s and then
that correlation kind of weakens
yeah you know
in the palm in the later years
which is cool right you can just sort of
kind of see this but just all that to
say that like your
um
uh whatever text what I was saying
before that if you put in like a bunch
of random internet texts you get
everything that the internet is which is
some good stuff and some of that stuff
you know open source and then everything
else
um
uh so it's worth considering what that
means
word embedding this let's do it
um
so for word vectors we're going to use
Spacey uh just because it gives easy
access to glove the glove vectors
um if you're running this in the
notebook you will need to download this
you need to run this yeah
oh I don't know
I'm not sure I don't really I haven't
really used
notifications but ltk is another uh NLP
but the only like it's basically a
little heavy weight but like you can
also access the glove themselves and you
can process them and do all that stuff
all right this is easier for me
um here is a bunch of code uh that I'm
not really going to explain where it's
essentially just a kind of simpler way
of turning a document into a single uh
embedding and what we're doing is we're
just averaging all of the word embedding
in the document into one vector which is
you know hacky and probably loses a lot
of information but what we want to get
is that document level representation
that we can just plug into our
classifier
um so again untuned right we're just
doing kind of a simple approach yeah but
not a dumb question but um in general
how do you approach your problem of like
when to make your own class for
vectorizer rather than using boiling oh
yeah I'm not sure yeah so
yeah I guess if I don't see a
Transformer that uh a second learn
Transformer that does what I wanted to
do I will just make my own
um and they're they're not too
complicated to make it because you've
got to fit
what you want to do how do you how do
you correctly evaluate that probably
threshold
oh yeah I mean good question so asking
about
um when do I decide to build my own
transformer and I guess
yeah I don't know if there's I don't
know if I have like a rule or heuristic
for that
um I mean I didn't didn't see anything
that did something like this in
scikit-learn so I just did it myself the
reason I like tease it out like this
it's faster to do it this way than to
shove everything through Spacey and have
it process each individual document in
this case it's taking the vocabulary
that I fit to the text turning each of
those words into a word writing and then
and then just multiplying the word
counts by them it's it's something that
I've done before and like I I didn't
used to do it in like in this format and
I guess I could learn for format but
I've more recently discovered how
powerful pipeline piece is so that's
I don't know if that's it yeah
so yeah so I'm just using that
Transformer and creating a document
level representation
and our performance is sorry I shouldn't
rerun it uh but our performance is not
bad right we've gone from 1500
Dimensions to 200 Dimensions we didn't
do too much tuning besides just taking
the average of an entire documents word
embeddings
um and we got you know
one sort of 84.
4 not bad
still not 87 right but uh
yeah still on 87 it's possible that this
might be a little bit more generalized
so where are we at now gosh time flies
Okay
um so we might need to just jump ahead
to the interesting stuff
um so we're gonna actually leave the
bagging uh regimen and we're going to
talk about
um
uh one of the things that we are missing
from all of our representations we're
throwing everything to bag right we're
decontextualizing all of the language
even with the word vectors right word
vectors have General representations of
uh of a words context but not the
specific context in which we find the
word
um so this is funny
I don't know I'm just gonna explain the
joke right
um so it's the same spelling and
pronunciation it's a different meaning
right because you know well can mean
condition of well and also wishing well
um and it's all about context to
understand which kind of well uh should
be represented in the system
um
yes so there's a bunch of different ways
that we can represent context we don't
necessarily need to plug it into the
latest and greatest neural net model
right we can always just have like a
window around each visual word and do
things around like do things like that
um you know you can say you know
concatenate different embeddings
together or average you know bigrams of
embeddings and things like that you
don't necessarily need to uh
jump to the you know the end with neural
models because the question before about
named entity recognition right you can
do work to ensure that the uh that when
new occurs with New York that it's
represented differently than uh just new
on its own a bunch of stuff you can do
but we're not going to do any of that
we're just going to go to neural Nets
one slide on all of
all of the models
actually works but
um I'm going to try to describe this uh
kind of conceptually right and why this
is a useful representation or a use of
representation to use in this context
um uh so the idea of our current network
is it's sort of built for this kind of
sequential data uh where as the
um as the model sort of scans across the
sequence it carries with it some
information uh from the beginning of the
sequence and I really love this visual
because I think it gets at a couple of
different things it shows you that at
the end of the sentence you have a
representation that has some uh
contextual information from the entire
sequence
what it also shows you is that the
beginning of the sequence is kind of
underrepresented by the end of the
sequence and that's a problem right
because that long-term dependency
problem that I referred to ages ago now
uh where you know Ben watched the movie
he didn't like it uh when you get to he
in this model you're going to have a
very small contribution of
Ben me to that representation at the
word key but honestly you want to hire
you want more representation of that
right because it's informative to what
he needs
that's right like a breeze through that
explanation hopefully that makes sense
but one way of dealing with that is
these long short-term memory networks
which essentially incorporate ways of uh
upgrading certain information and
downloading other information losing
certain information remembering other
information that is useful for the
representation further down the line
remember that problem of long-term
dependency because it comes back does
this make sense I know this is one slide
apologize
there's nothing
so to the notebooks we're gonna just go
for it um so if you're actually
following along
um at home or somewhere
um you might want to change your runtime
type to uh GPU
uh for in collab because it'll run a lot
faster
because run it not on GPU it'll just
take longer
um this is a massive block of code that
I am not an expert deep learning
engineer so this probably is not the
best way to do it but it is a way of
building a fairly simple lstm model very
briefly this model will have essentially
a word in word embedding but that word
embedding is a little bit it's similar
to like the word embeddings that we've
been using but it's not kind of trained
for General contextual representation
it's trained for the purpose of this
sentiment analysis so you could slice
out this word embeddings and use this
for some purpose but it probably
wouldn't be as useful as like a glove
but this is the idea is the same the
model is going to learn a representation
of individual tokens
lsdm this is this is doing all the work
um we have some uh dimensionality of the
input that's going to come into it we
have some hidden representation that
goes as the model sort of scans across
the sequence
um and then essentially basically have a
logistic regression
settings
it's called the data you're providing
rather than actually looking up
right yeah but you can
um like this yeah it's really simple to
say you have a pre-trained embedding and
tell the model and actually it would
help it right that model has to now
learn oh sorry the question was these
are not reading in um pre-trained
embeddings these are learning events so
it's learning embeddings and learning
the classification so you might actually
be helped by using a pre-trained event
um this takes the classification of the
the final output of the lstm
um you get a representation of each step
in the sequence though
but in this case you're just taking the
last
step so that
part taking the class
um
this is a bunch of uh code to kind of
engineer it so that it works well with
the model
um we're creating going from documents
to token into indices in the in the
vocabulary
um and we're also you'll notice
subsetting it to just the first 200
tokens and the uh in the review which
problematic rate there's probably a lot
more information to maintain actually in
the we're embeddings we're doing better
right because we're using all of the
tokens that are in the um the review
and then this is a lot of stuff that is
initially happening to process it and
turn it into something that can be
ingested to the pi torch training
um
I'm trying to think there's anything I
want to call out here I'm using tfidf
vectorizer here just to get the
vocabulary
was thinking to get the vocabulary out
of it and to also get the tokenizer out
of it which will enable me to look up in
the vocabulary the index of the term
um and then there's a bunch of model
parameters that is that I you know I
don't have a particular opinion these
are things that I've seen used the
hidden dimension of 512 and then betting
dimension of 400
um doesn't necessarily need to be that
output size in this case
um I've found it works better or makes
more sense to use it
um for this binary classification as
appetized one because we just want a
prediction of is it positive or not and
if it's not it's negative rather than
two classes I think you could probably
make this two classes but
um
then a bunch of work happens here in
terms of doing the training
um I am using uh I'm uh printing the
loss for validation based on the test
set don't do that
um I think probably there's a lot of
tutorials today that will do the same
thing where it's just like you know
whatever we have two splits but you want
a different validation set than your
test set usually
um
but uh this is just training it from one
Epoch
um and if you run it it should run
pretty quickly for one Epoch you won't
see
um you may not see as good results as we
can get if we train it for longer but
just from one Epoch you'll get something
like 82
so accuracy of 82.
an F1 score of like 83. so pretty
comparable to our uh
word bettings without much additional
tuning or work around it
um
sequence is 200. so it's 200 tokens is
I mean it's based on your data like uh
these reviews are actually pretty long
on average
some of them are really long
if you're dealing with like sentences or
something like that
uh length sequence right
um so it depends
and like sometimes you might want to
there's some functionality to like turn
them into individual
um uh like split them up essentially
rather than just like truncate them
um I like Pine torch only because I like
the syntax in uh hugging faces
Transformers library for pi torch rather
than tensorflow it's just I don't know
it makes more sense to me
yeah yeah I'm not like heavy duty deep
learning engineer right so I
to wrestle with this too much but
my torch
I like
cool uh what are we at in terms of time
okay so we're gonna in like 10 minutes
describe all of Transformers
so one of the main issues spoiler of
recurrent neural networks is they still
have a hard time with these long
passages
um
and they're harder to train right
they're harder to parallelize uh one
solution to that is so this is just an
example of long-term dependencies is uh
introduced as the idea of attention
right so if I'm giving this example of
Ben watch the movie today he didn't like
it you can imagine that
um uh the representation for he should
have some uh should carry with it some
information about the word Ben right
like I've sort of referenced this before
attention kind of operationalizes that
more
each individual token has some weighting
of uh importance on the representation
for other tokens and that's essentially
all of what attention does it's trying
to mimic our own process with language
where we know when we're looking at he
we know where to look back to we know
just intrinsically where that reference
trying to teach the model to do that
same thing and this is a visualization
of those those weights the intensity of
those weights and I'm curating a little
bit because there's a bunch of different
you know attention weights and usually
different layers to that but this is a
very clear example
um this is sort of
syntax essentially where it'll have a
classification token which is for the
usually used for classification
represent like has an intention to all
of the tokens and the separation which
is like the end of
now I'm going to explain all Transformer
models in one slide
um so again I'm glossing over a lot so
there's an entire world of encoder
decoder models which I haven't even
touched on but this is a adaptation of
that to really Leverage The Power of
attention
um and the things that are most
important to kind of understand is that
the encoder takes inputs uh all the
inputs for the entire sequence creates
intention across that entire sequence
has an output of the encoded outputs
that goes into the decoder the decoder
takes its current state where what it
what it has currently decoded and that
encoder representation
and outputs
and output you know whether that's like
another sequence like translation or
something like that from English to
French or something
and so what's important to understand
about that is you the only information
about the position of the individual
tokens comes from that positional
encoding so you can do like a lot of uh
you can do parallelization makes it
easier paralyzed
in previous
um previous States
uh but the decoder
um uh the decoder uh
the example that I'm going to what I'm
going to be focusing on here is
something that's called a language model
and the language model objective is to
predict the next word
right so in that sort of Paradigm the
decoder can't be able to see the rest of
the sequence right because otherwise the
decoder would just predict the rest of
the sequence right it already has it so
it's sort of blinded uh like going
forward and the future studies and you
can understand that that you know it's a
blind spot that is maybe makes the model
a little bit
um
weaker like that probably you want that
the strength of this encoding is that it
has the entire sequence all at once they
can consider everything sort of at once
which is pretty powerful but with the
vanilla trans Transformer it it doesn't
in the decoder step it doesn't have the
entire sequence
the only reason I spend some time
explaining that is because that is the
difference essentially between a vanilla
Transformer and
burp
Robert is encoder only
and it sees the entire sequence at once
but to get around the fact that it's now
seeing everything and it has to predict
something in that sequence there is uh
it replaces some portion of the tokens
that are input into it with a special
mask token or with a random token and
then an app the objective is for the
model to predict that that replaced
so it's a similar thing to this language
it's the same idea it's still a language
model but in this case it's it doesn't
have to do special binding to one aspect
of it and it is solely an encoder it
doesn't have the decoder component so
simplified and has the full view over
the entire sequence
and I do that was the entire
two years of NLP two years three years
something like that our numbers
yeah so there's a conceptual
understanding there's a lot of modulo a
bunch of like fancy math stuff that
happens but
conceptually I feel like that explains
it
okay so we're coming very close to the
end I will just sort of leave with this
piece
um so uh Bert you will uh in the
notebook you will install the
Transformers you will load a pipeline
that's called sentiment analysis that
does a bunch of truncation and padding
for you uh you will apply it I just
apply it to 50 of them to make it doable
and you will get an incredible
performance uh congratulations you are
now state of the art NLP developers and
the reason I say that kind of
tongue-in-cheek is because like this is
you know we've gotten 0.88 versus 0.87
from the beginning of the the top right
um
yeah so you don't need to jump to the
bird is not always like just plugging in
but it doesn't necessarily make sense
um it's a lot of complexity that you're
adding on to it and it may not get you
that much
um and furthermore because of the
amazing open source Community it's this
easy to use perk right now something I
didn't really get to is some stuff at
the bottom where you probably want to
tune or to your context but again you
get marginal improvements
so that kind of concludes it
um I have some just general advice which
is sort of what I've been saying the
entire time which you want to start
simple makes you better unable and to
understand your use case your data all
that stuff and then add complexity
rather than go all the way because it's
the latest
um
and that's it
a bunch of interesting materials there
feel free to get in touch if you're
interested in the Institute also get in
touch or get in touch with them but I
will take yeah any questions
foreign
[Music]
it's essentially distilled the
information that Bert has into it
smaller
is Stillberg yeah
no you can yeah it's just it's you you
have access to it with a Transformers
Library
um you have access to all these
different models and Distillery is just
one structure of making it lighter
there's
there's a bunch
so let's see how's the explainability on
bird or
like that because you showed it so
nicely with logistic right at the
beginning right you know we get
coefficient way that goes to each one
how do we know what's happening with
work yeah
um I feel like you don't
um
uh you get representation like you know
uh if you peel off this that
classification layer you do
for each individual
that is contextualized so like well
right like the word well could be a
different representation in context of
Wishing Well versus I am doing well
compare that to word events
so really cool stuff you can do with
that you can you know say how similar
these two words are with the contextual
information
and then you can interpret that to mean
something to have some meaning to this
but it's uh
but like Dimensions themselves again
don't have a readily interpretable
presentation so
I think there's a bunch of work I don't
not too familiar with it with using
these like interpreting what these like
how these models are coming to the
decision that they're coming to but
that's sort of
assuming that this model has learned
stuff that is valuable we can interpret
what that value is
an interesting approach
all right that's not a very satisfying
answer to your question there's always
more to explore
yeah it's it changes probably like half
the stuff is now
yeah exactly
I've absolutely
whatever
you feel like this coexist
I mean this recognition
first and then move on to like how you
how would you organize I would say it
depends on what your use case is if
you're
if you're seeing the
person like a attracting people or
tracking places and then like say if
you're like looking at product reviews
and you want to see you know if people
mention a particular product you might
want to just like
like throwing bird in there is going to
get you a nice representation of it but
unless you're using Bert that is that is
for the identity recognition sorry yeah
it's there are different use cases
um for the sentiment uh analysis
pipeline dude you know I'm just kind of
wondering like for can you can you just
use the bird embedding
for other purpose like can you fit I I
assume you can just take that and put it
in the logistic regression as well yeah
so have you have you ever kind of played
around with that I have I've actually
used this so that classification token
has you know essentially it has a
representation that includes the entire
sequence
um and you could use that for whatever
right
um
yeah and I've used it in the same way
that you might use a document level
I don't necessarily think that's maybe
it's probably not the best way to do it
there's burnt models that are
particularly for these like longer
sequences that might do a better job of
that but yeah the representations are
useful
in fact I think that pipeline uses that
I'm not sure
any other questions
thank you very much
[Applause]